hey this is fresh tell Walker a ants
start at different corners of the cube
suddenly each ant moves to an adjacent
corner at random that is each ant walks
along one of its three adjacent edges
with equal chance what is the
probability that none of the ants
collide I received this problem by email
from Dave carpenter and it's quite
fascinating can you figure it out give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching the video for the solution
so let's first consider the total number
of ways that the ants can move each ant
can move along three possible edges the
total number of paths for eight ants
equals the product of the number of
possibilities for each ant this means
the total number of paths will be 3 to
the power of 8 which equals 65-61
now we need to count the number of paths
in which the ants do not collide so one
way the ants might not collide is that
the ants on opposite phases rotate
positions for example we could have the
ants on the top face rotate positions
and have the ants on the bottom face
rotate positions here's one way that the
ants could move so that they would not
collide but that's not the only
possibility for the ants on the top and
the bottom faces for each face the ants
can move in two directions either
clockwise or counterclockwise so we have
to consider that there will be more
possibilities here's another way that
the ants could move in which they would
not collide here's another way and there
will also be one more fourth way that
the ants on the top and bottom faces
will not collide in total the ants on
each face can move either clockwise or
counterclockwise and there are two faces
so that means two times two which equals
four possibilities for each pair
of opposite faces now just for fun I'm
going to show you all of these
possibilities for the top and bottom
faces at once so you can see the answer
moving in different directions in each
of these four different cubes
furthermore we've only considered top
and bottom faces but they're gonna be
three pairs of opposite faces on a cube
we've just Illustrated top and bottom
but we can also do the same sort of
thing for the front and back faces and
we could do the same sort of thing for
the left and right faces where the aunts
in these faces rotate positions with
each other so how many different ways
have we just figured out well they're
four different ways for each pair of
opposite faces and there are three kinds
of opposite faces that makes for 4 times
3 which equals 12 ways the aunts do not
collide but there is more there's
another way that the aunts could not
collide which is that all eight of the
aunts can move in a loop a closed path
that goes through every vertex exactly
once is called a Hamiltonian cycle now
to preempt a comment it will go through
every vertex exactly once except for the
vertex that's both at the start at the
end which is visited twice so with that
caveat we have the definition of a
cameltoe nyan cycle so we want to figure
out how many Hamiltonian cycles there
are for the cube so this will be a
little bit more difficult to show you so
rather than going through this 3d model
I'm actually going to flatten out the
cube this is known as a cubicle graph
and it's a 2d version of the cube so
let's illustrate the number of
Hamiltonian cycles let me clean up this
diagram and now I'm gonna tell you there
are actually six undirected Hamiltonian
cycles you can imagine if you start at
one vertex there'll be three choices and
then for the second vertex that you go
to there will be two more choices so
here's one example of a Hamiltonian
cycle now let me go ahead and illustrate
all of the other ones as well
now this front face involves three
different edges
that of going through this loop but
Udall said the front face have exactly
two of its edges involved in a loop so
here are the remaining Hamiltonian
cycles so these are six undirected
Hamiltonian cycles for each of these we
can actually place directions to create
the ways that the ants might possibly
flow on the cube
these are directed Hamiltonian cycles
now this is one way that we could draw
the arrows but we can also draw the
arrows in the opposite direction
therefore for each undirected
Hamiltonian cycle we have two possible
directions for the loop so this means
since each loop can be traversed in two
directions there are twelve directed
Hamiltonian cycles in other words twelve
ways that the ants could move so that
they would not collide so now let's
calculate the answer there are 24 total
ways that the ants will not collide we
have 12 cases from case one and twelve
cases from case two this is out of a
total of 65 61 possible ways the ants
could move therefore the probability
that there's no collision will be 24
divided by 65 61 which equals 8 out of
20 187 which is approximately 0.37%
it's a very slim chance that the ants
will not collide but it involves very
interesting geometrical loops that are
on the cube did you figure it out thanks
for watching this video please subscribe
to my channel I make videos on Mac you
can catch free on my blog mind your
decisions that you can follow on
Facebook Google+ and patreon you can
catch her on social media at pressure
Larker and if you liked this video
please check out my books there are
links in the video description